هذه محادثة نصية
قبل لحظات فقط من محاولة المشتبه به البالغ من العمر 18 عامًا
قتل جدته ،
ثم في كلماته أطلق النار على
مدرسة ابتدائية أنت تعرف ما
سأفعله الآن يكتب لي أخبرني أن
الرد لا يمكنني  نظرًا لأن جدي لم
يغادر ، فأنا أنتظر أن يغادر هذا الرجل
بعد الساعة 11 صباحًا بوقت قصير بتوقيت تكساس ،
ثم يشكو المشتبه فيه من
جدته وفاتورة هاتفه ، فأنا
أنتظر هذا ،
وسأفعل شيئًا لها الآن
.  مع مرور الوقت حول هاتفي ،
إنه أمر مزعج بعد مرور خمس دقائق ، ثم
أطلقت للتو النار على جدتي في الرأس ،
سأذهب إلى مدرسة
ابتدائية الآن
تلك الرسالة الأخيرة التي تم إرسالها في الساعة 6 و 21 مساءً بتوقيت ألمانيا
والتي كانت ستبلغ 11 و 21 صباحًا.  في
أوفالدي تكساس بعد 11 دقيقة ،
تلقت الشرطة أول مكالمة لها لإطلاق النار
في مدرسة روب الابتدائية ، الشخص الموجود في
الطرف المتلقي لتلك الرسائل ،
فتاة تبلغ من العمر 15 عامًا في ألمانيا لم
تقابل المشتبه به شخصيًا من
خلال تطبيق البث المباشر  يُدعى
yubo ثم أرسل رسالة نصية إلى أنه أرسل مقاطع فيديو
لنفسه ، إنها ليست الشخص الوحيد الذي
كان يتواصل معه عبر حساب مطلق النار على
instagram أظهر صورة
لسلاحين من طراز ar
ووسم امرأة شابة أخرى أرسلها في صباح يوم
إطلاق النار قائلة إنني على وشك  إلى لكن
لم ينته من عقوبته وبعد ذلك
حصلت على سر صغير